les chéris ir la france a retenu son
souffle face à une annonce qu'on n'avait
pas vu à nantes étaient tous bien
entendu les yeux rivés sur ce qui se
passait en france aussi se passer aux
etats unis aussi parce qu'il se passe
des choses très graves aux états unis
non mais c'est vrai ailleurs on va en
parler bien sûr dans cette émission est
fière et bien afida turner que vous
connaissez 7 à 19 heures françaises 13h
à american 2h heure chinoise publié un
tweet des fans dire français je vous
annonce ma candidature à la
présidentielle afin de remédier au
problème des gilets jaunes et de
surcroît à cette piopolis violente alors
afida turner est avec nous merci d'être
là afida a bon soir afida merci alors
merci afida merci voila voila merci pour
la personne afida donc vous allez donc
vous présenter aux élections
présidentielles en france c'est bien ça
c'est en france c'est à dire qu'en fait
en premier lieu je n'aime pas
l'injustice j'ai été bouleversée autres
essais passés à minneapolis a eu aussi
bien aux sea dogs avaient assassiné en
direct avec trois de ses compères qui
qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas sauvé
sept personnes non assistance à personne
en danger
c'est vrai j'ai été et très attristé je
trouve ça très triste et donc j'ai été
poussé par une force spirituelle et de
dieu je me suis je dois apporter quelque
chose au peuple français au peuple
américain et au noir ou peu importe ce
qui s'est passé c'est terrible je suis
très attristé donc j'ai voulu en fait
apporté ma notoriété pouvoir faire des
choses positives je trouve ça très
triste également ce qui se passe aux
états-unis en france avec cet épisode a
flat justement parce que voilà on rigole
beaucoup avec afi là c'est vrai qu'on
est dans le second degré etc
mais c'est vrai que ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis ça doit nous servir et de
leçons c'est de servir de leçon à toutes
les polices du monde
je vous le dis et c'est vrai que il faut
arrêter avec ces techniques
je vous le dis voilà on l'a vu ce qui
s'est passé aussi en france j'avais eu
un reportage poignant dans balances ton
post d'une famille aussi qui avait perdu
son papa d'une jeune fille qui avait
perdu son papa
franchement ça ça doit être djoudi une
des priorités pour moi du gouvernement
et du ministre de l'intérieur parce que
je pense qu'on peut faire régner l'ordre
mais voilà dans tous les pays du monde
on doit arrêter ces techniques
d'étouffement mais ils n'ont rien parce
que voilà ça a été on a tous vu les
images de tous de ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis
et franchement ces images sont
insoutenables moi je me suis en plus
renseignés sur sur ce garçon est encore
plus les cc c'est vraiment joli
je pense que tout le monde se renseigne
sur ce garçon ce moment est vraiment
c'est une énorme bavure justice voilà
une injustice à lui et je vous dis moi
je suis voilà je joue 10 et ça doit être
une des priorités du gouvernement parce
qu'il faut pas que non plus que ça
arrive en france c'est déjà arrivé
ce que voilà on l'a vu on en a parlé
donc je vous dis j'ai eu un témoignage
très fort dans balances ton post donc
c'est vrai qu'on rigole avec afida
c'est un peu du second degré sont
d'élections ça sa candidature mais c'est
vrai que là on parle de faire d'autres
choses très graves
et voilà je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on
en parle qu'on en discute et que mine de
rien on puisse débattre avec le ministre
de l'intérieur prochainement de ça dans
un btp ou dans une autre émission même
pas chez moi je suis pas voilà je m'en
fous moi que ça se débattent ailleurs
mais il faut vraiment arrêter toutes les
techniques
voilà d'étouffement parce que c'est
c'est catastrophique et je peux vous
dire que ça va faire d'énormes dégâts et
et voilà moi je vous dis moi j'ai été
écoeuré par ce qui s'est passé là bas
aux états unis par ces images je pense
qu'on l'a tous étaient 1
je devais voulait rencontrer aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je n'ai même pas fait j'ai
pas envie c'est insoutenable c'est pas
cela la mort d'un homme en direct quoi
c'est insoutenable
je te dis en plus bien sûr il épargnera
épargnez moi qui dit jean ne respire
plus qui dit arrêté et des mois arrêtés
non mais c'est un soutenant le pansement
et vous allez je pense vraiment et voilà
un fidèle contre oui oui qui dit oui
surtout que c'est quand même une
technique qui a été réitérée en france
il ya deux trois jours on l'a vu en
vidéo sur twitter
moi je pense que si afida elle peut
faire parler de ça et combattre ça en
faisant croire qu'elles se présentent
aux élections et bah pourquoi pas ça
fait pas ça fait parler ça fait avancer
bon bah fida où tout cela vraiment là je
pense qu'il faut surtout regarder ont
lancé par la province et bien sûr tout
s'adresser aussi aux hautes instances
mine de rien il arrête ces techniques et
notamment au ministre de l'intérieur ou
christophe castaner si nous regardent
aujourd'hui
afida qu'est ce que vous voulez vous
présenter en france vous
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
êtes prêts à faire pour les français
pourquoi c'est une blague ou bien ou
bien voulez vraiment vous présenter ses
peines en premier lieu j'ai été
bouleversé par l'injustice de george
north et d'abîmer daverat où on vient
d'en parler un feed ah mais c'est vrai
que vous voulez vous présenter en france
aussi oui mais bien évidemment je suis
américain des françaises mais je sais
qu'ils se passe malheureusement des
hausses d énormes problèmes en france
mais aussi des des grosses bavures et
beaucoup de violence dans la justice
policière française
on a pu constater la même chose avec un
policier avec le genou a parlé oui on en
a parlé et c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu on a
même payé
l'émission a dessus sur de relance ton
pote eux mais récemment récemment
récemment aussi on l'a vu sur twitter
aussi ya des jours où ça inadmissible ce
garçon georges laoun aider à henri
citoyen américain de 46 ans qui a été
assassinée en direct le sauver cas ici
et compères qui n'ont pas manifesté
ils ne l'ont pas défendu également
qu'ils sont aussi qu'on parle c'est pour
moi oui boue c'est une honte assistance
à personne en danger s'est régalé à
petit la gfa apporter un soutien urgent
il est jaune comment ces gens peuvent
vivre avec 800 euros par mois
quant au montant des droits on préfère
aller en tire la france et l'économie
plutôt que leur met une augmentation ces
finalistes celle de lens doit arrêter et
ce gouvernement et donc je préférais en
fait apporté ma notoriété pour faire
quelque chose de plus steve pas
seulement deux candidats à sida vous
savez qu'il faut il faut 500 signatures
de maires sa mine de rien on a parlé
nage de 500 maires de france qui
pourrait vous parrainez escaut course et
les avoir on a 300 des 300 villages mais
c'est à dire c'est pas pareil c'est pas
du soutien c'est pas des mères c'est pas
des soutiens les fans c'est pas des
parents à
adacore à bob bissonnette et la saône
est elle allée votre vie qu'afida ou et
c'est quoi votre programme
c'est quoi votre programme en quoi votre
programme
c'est quoi mais je manifeste à miami
pour la mort par le président et son
adresse
nous manifestons blâma le blanc noah là
je pense que cette histoire de sol ne
vont pas tuer des innocents
elles manifestent pacifiquement
quoique lentement ah non c'est à ces
mondiale doit s que sks que manifester
pacifiquement au final n'ont pas
pacifiquement
on vous entend crevale afida
malheureusement afida juste oui mais
alimentant rabat merci papa de sa
jeunesse le frangin amer afida arrêté on
en a parlé on en a parlé et c'est vrai
que ça a ému toute la planète
on le redit et c'est bien d'en reparler
aujourd'hui mais moi c'est presque tous
les coups on vous pose une question
mais là oui mais s'est effondré c'est
quoi votre programme marine il présente
un programme économique votre programme
c'est quoi mon programme économique
s'est déjà des délais gilet jaune
comment ces gens il avec 800 euros par
référendum et on dort on dort dans des
droits de soi on peut enfin mauvaise et
et détruire détruire détruire l'économie
parisienne donné au gie les jeunes ce
qui leur doit donner l'heure une
augmentation arrêtons arrêtons ce drame
mais tout ça fleure afida c'est une
blague de votre candidature ou bien
vraiment vous pensé aller au bout nicole
oui
savait à qui vous avez affaire jeune
blake j'avais on a 300 mhz et oui les
trois cent mille isles mêmes et ça sympa
présidente je je j'aimerais apporter mon
soutien dans ces moments là au gilet
jaune comme afida vous pensez que vous
pouvez peser sur la prochaine élection
vous savez mon prix d'incommensurables
nda et vous savez oui mais alors à
remonter sa volonté incroyable qu'est ce
que j'aimerais aider le vogue français
surtout les gilet jaune
comment on laisse une économie française
détruites
quand finalement peu juste leur donner
une augmentation à ses ouvriers
ces gens comment voulez vous allez rire
les journalistes à la tribune
bonsoir ne comprend pas l'anglais le
parc arabe leicester city
non juste une question puisque vous
dites que vous voulez aller au bout de
votre candidature n'est pas une farce et
que vraiment vous avez vous semblez être
extrêmement investi il faut il cire il
l'a dit un parrainage il faut il faut
donc prendre son bâton de pèlerin venir
en france
aller frapper aux portes des maires et
les convaincre chacun chacun de ces
mères là les convaincre leur
développement leur programme et le
programme et en disant voilà je vous
demande de me paraît n'est pas ce que je
voudrais que vous appuyez ma candidature
comme qu'est ce que vous allez dire à
ces mères comme quand vous allez les
voir la france pour qu'ils appuient
votre candidature qu'est ce que vous
leur direz au delà des généralités parce
qu'on est tous d'accord
évidemment qu'on veut tous être que que
les plus faibles soient soient mieux
rémunérés qui soit mieux protégé que ça
ira mais comment qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que vous proposez concrètement oui
valérie je vais vous répondre on dirait
c'est à dire qu'avec 300 kg de truites
et 300000 ac
j'aimerais juste en fait pouvoir aider
les gens vous comprenez je veux dire que
la vérité
et les fans et le public est roi
je suis une femme du public je suis né
orpheline je me bats tous les jours de
tourisme p'tit gars en comprenait à foix
pas une fille de rachida et le peuple le
peuple le souverain pour salon amg des
résidents mais en tout cas je pourrais
apporter pas fait drôlement mon aide aux
gens qui ont besoin vous comprenez et
valérie vous allez vous allez vous
également venir avec moi à oui dans la
valise les jambes parce que vous vous
posez la question vous devez tenir
également vous devez supporter
ridha ma chérie juste afida est ce que
vous savez on va revoir va pas se mentir
il ya plein de gens qui se moquent de
vous qui lie ces conneries et c'est
n'importe quoi même nous ce soir et on
on va se marrer afida turner qui se
présente aux présidentielles car il faut
avouer voilà on s'est dit on va se
marrer c'est n'importe quoi c'est une
connerie qu'est ce que vous avez à dire
à ces gens là
moi j'ai à dire que le public le public
et les fans
ce sont eux les vrais les vrais
supporters vous chantez chevron 0,38
euro temps là même si je ne viens pas
président en tout cas je pourrais aider
bénévolement et arrêter cette violence
de la police et pouvoir aider les gens
même si c'est bénévolement vous
comprenez bien faits d'armes jean michel
naud simplement juste une petite
question afida est ce que vous comptez
faire quelque chose c'est un certain
sourcils qui sont danger dans le monde
notamment à miami
parce que parce que pour les sourcils la
problème est que les sourcils on a rien
compris la vanne de genre du ciel mais
relevé que les sourcils à l'essai à
fillols oui bon non assistance à
sourcils en danger oui c'est pas marrant
merci joly merci afida afida est ce que
vous avez déjà un slogan de campagne yes
là d'accord qui veut dire oui il existe
des chasses existe des invités de nages
parce que c'est un très beau ce taux que
vous avez ça existe déjà une section
parce qu'il n'y en a peut-être oui j'ai
dit c'est dommage parce que c'est un
très très beau slogan effectivement qui
a été lancée quand il ya eu assassinat à
freud bien sûr des afro américains
mais c'est en avançant sur en français
basque et hoitz l'oat française
la seconde nous rassemblant une fois il
faut lutter
artak justice aller plus loin justice ok
ok si on demande plus d'efforts pour
bosser un peu quand même à villach parce
que c'est pas jacques séguéla
bon merci à villach vous embrasse fort
en tout cas vers 6h fida merci d'avoir
été ma série mercy mercy alors elle a
raison sur un truc hein les images de ce
genre de scandale pas puisqu'elle est
vraiment inadmissible on peut pas nier
qu'elle est en tout cas si je lui ai dit
la vérité parce que c'est avec tout le
monde se moque d'elle voile aérien c'est
ce que nous disent des choses voilà
reinhardt en panne attention moi je me
moque plus là moi je pensais que c'était
pour déconner qu'elle faisait sa salle à
saint-girons confirme donc moi je me
gausse si j'étais parti pour ça c'était
pour avoir trois cent mille euros tweet
j'ai déconné pour faire trois cent mille
euros tweet c'est sérieux la politique
c'est la vie des gens la politique on
peut pas arriver comme ça et faire tout
et n'importe quoi surtout avec
l'actualité qui se passe en ce moment
mois de juin et j'adresse un message à
monsieur castaner aussi faut arrêter
contre le moulin delight faut arrêter et
totalement maîtrisé que vous êtes 3 sur
lui à quoi ça sert de venir s'est
raréfiée dans la tête en vélo de faire
l'amour finit là mais là le mec le fic
america on voit les flics américains
il ya des trucs aussi en france qui sont
lavés 19 condamnations et aurait dû
l'arrêter parce que ça vous savez vous
parlez de du meca qui a commis ce crime
cet assassinat mais il ya eu aussi le
policier asiatique assurant que les gens
lui il faut qu'il aille au placard à
zéralda corps et les de l'autre qui
était avec lui au placard aussi c'est
désormais un accent d'un être humain
saint valentin on peut pas rester comme
ça insensible devant ce qui s'est passé
et c'est vrai qu'en france et je te
rejoins et on le répète il faut vraiment
qu'ils fixent à de l'intérieur
christophe castaner ça serve de leçon un
peu vide d'air exactement parce que
voilà c'est des trucs qui sont
intolérables ça tu peux pas perdre la
vie avec un cac et 107e protéger ta vie
fut d'accord il ay les ça y est le mec
il est maîtrisé mettez le dans la
voiture exactement à passer devant la
justice il a répondu c'est son papa ce
truc de ayant voté oui des policiers
sont associés
on a déjà parlé ici la lampe à d'un
autre problème suite c'est quand le mec
est maîtrisée ou n'avait pas besoin de
ça à ça que je trouve bien aller mais
qu'on verra ce que dira final les maires
de france sont pas si achetable qui leur
seraient oui merci parce que là alalala
via l'ademe elle a raison de dire que
juste rajouter aux gens qui nous
regardent vite fait je vais chanter 10
secondes
les élections présidentielles ces deux
tours c'est pas un tour souvenez-vous du
passé on va pas voter le premier samedi
on va faire des barbecues on va chez
gilbert faire la terrasse deuxième
j2ee au deuxième tour on se retrouve
avec deux candidats que les gens disent
avec moi j'en voulais aucun des deux ces
deux tours les élections je lé là je le
dise je dis aux gens face caméra ces
deux tours vous réveillez pas après en
disant oui mais celui-là gens voulaient
pas j'ai pas voté pour lui et maintenant
il ya les gilet jaune et ceci cela